Згідно з новим американським законопроєктом,
як повідомляється на сайті одного з авторів документа,
сенатора Джона Баррасо, санкції США тепер
мають поширитися не лише на компанії, які займаються безпосередньо
роботами з прокладення трубопроводу, а й на тих,
хто надає їм страхову або юридичну допомогу,
а також портові послуги.
Серед іншого штрафні заходи можуть бути застосовані й проти компаній,
які нададуть сертифікацію газопроводу
"Північний потік-2" для початку експлуатації.
Сенатор Джон Баррасо, як і інші ініціатори нового законопроєкту, переконаний:
"Газопровід Nord Stream 2 - це російська пастка.
Вона робить Європу і союзників США більш залежними від Росії
й більш піддатливими її впливу.
Ми зобов'язуємося блокувати всі зусилля Росії
з будівництва цього небезпечного трубопроводу".
Нагадаємо, що прокладання труб зупинено з грудня минулого року.
У компанії Nord Stream 2 коментувати - цитата -
"спекуляції про продовження будівництва" трубопроводу відмовилися.
У відповідь на запит DW щодо розширення санкцій США
офіційний представник Nord Stream 2 зазначив,
що енергетичні компанії Західної Європи, а саме
з Австрії, Німеччини, Франції та Нідерландів,
вклали в цей проєкт приблизно по мільярду євро.
Тим часом, на думку багатьох аналітиків,
крім політичної складової проєкту
питання викликає і його економічна доцільність.
Для енергопостачання Європи нагальної необхідності в цьому немає.
На даний момент на ринку спостерігається надлишок пропозиції зрідженого газу,
з чим газу з труби нині важко конкурувати.
Схожу думку висловлювали раніше й інші експерти.
Нині нікому в Європі газ не потрібен.
Опалювальний сезон пройшов, наступний почнеться в жовтні.
Сховища порівняно з минулими роками переповнені,
тому що ця зима була знову тепла. Попит на газ впав.
Ці питання знову почнуть підніматися, коли
зросте попит або зміниться кон'юнктура, якщо будуть зроблені
якісь нові прогнози або знову посилиться роль газових електростанцій.
Я очікую, що з витісненням не тільки атомної енергетики,
але й "брудної" вугільної енергетики в Європі,
і особливо в Німеччині, роль газових електростанцій буде зростати,
і за рахунок цього попит на газ теж зростатиме.
Що стосується Німеччини, то політики
в більшості своїй продовжують підтримувати "Північний потік-2".
Так, у федеральній землі Мекленбург-Передня Померанія
наміри американських сенаторів щодо нових санкцій піддали різкій критиці.
Там навіть прозвучали заклики ввести санкції у відповідь.
Власне, й офіційний Берлін свого ставлення до проєкту поки не змінив.
Ось як відповів міністр закордонних справ Німеччини
на питання про погрози ввести нові санкції:
- Я принаймні не можу сказати, що з якого б то не було боку
є необхідність в обговоренні теми про трубоукладача.
Аби розширення санкцій вступило в силу,
законопроєкту необхідно пройти через обидві палати Конгресу,
після чого документ мав би підписати президент Дональд Трамп.
Утім, як відзначають німецькі оглядачі,
щодо санкцій проти трубопроводу "Північний потік-2"
серед представників провідних політичних сил у США
панує для нинішніх часів рідкісна одностайність.